let's get started
um and I was gonna say can you see my
screen but I realized that we are
offline yeah
um but anyway yeah thank you very much
for coming to my talk this is a gender
introduction to scaling up machine
learning service with kubernetes and ml
flow
um
I'm happy to see all of you in the
audience I guess using lots of buzzwords
in the title worked well
right
before we begin
um it's gonna be mainly about the uh
introduction to kubernetes service
deployment so I expect you to know the
darker basics of docker
so yep
so let me quickly introduce myself uh my
name is kaini Moto I'm a data scientist
at the Montefiore Einstein Center for
Health Data Innovations in my work I
mostly do email Ops type stuff I build
CI CD pipelines
ETL pipelines in my previous
organization I was developing the back
end and I was developing NLP models a
lot uh this is my LinkedIn account I'm
happy to get connected with you and this
is my GitHub account
um
and uh I'm gonna show some code uh for
this talk and um all code is available
on my GitHub so please check out
okay so let's get started so let's
imagine that you're working as a machine
learning engineer and one of uh the data
scientists
um in your team
um developed a random first model all
right let's say Iris prediction
and you are asked to deploy the machine
learning model as a microservice so this
is our Tech stack would look like so the
random Forest is implemented in psychi
run and we're gonna use flask to to
create a rest endpoint and we're gonna
use a g unicorn as a whiskey HTTP server
and we're gonna package everything into
darker containers
so this is just the example code for the
flask service I hope nothing new here so
the model is random first classifier and
we Implement a post method in flask and
it receives requests as a Json we pass
the Json input into model.predict model
generates prediction and we generate a
response including a prediction and
Returns the response as additions Json
string Okay so
so if we visualize
um the deployment strategy
um for this model
um it would look like this and uh let's
call this single container deployment
so
first we have a host VM and on the host
node we have a Docker container running
and within the darker container there's
G unicorn server running and the service
running and so on and there should be a
bridge between the docker specific port
and the host VMS Port so the connection
is established and client can send a
HTTP request to the host VM specific
port and
since the request hits the the node it's
going to be forwarded to the G unicorn
unicorn sends the request to the flask
service
it's gonna generate a response using the
circular model and since the response
back to the client
so this is uh similar to what I did in
the past uh in my work I was happy I
finished my task
um I went home cooked dinner I went to
my bed and
this happened
so let's uh let's review like what went
wrong with a single container deployment
what are the problems
so the first problem is straightforward
if the host VM goes down your service
goes down and uh VMS fail for many
reasons and I learned my lesson
in a very bad way
and what about update downtime while
you're upgrading your service from V1 to
V2 you have to switch
um your container from V1 to V2 so there
is gonna be a update downtime and this
means that your service is not highly
available which is not a great thing for
the production service
and what about scalability
um the resource resources of the
container are bound to the resources of
the host node so your darker container
cannot be bigger than the host node so
it's going to be a scalability issue
and to solve these uh problems I mean so
yeah um so this means that single
container deployment has an issue with
um scalability and high availability and
we want the production system to be
highly available and scalable to achieve
that we can use kubernetes
so what is kubernetes kubernetes is a
container management system
so let's think about the life cycle of
the continuous application so the life
cycle consists of these four stages the
first stage is the building you build
the image and the second stage is the
deployment you deploy your image into
some image repository and the next stage
is scheduling and scheduling means you
decide to when and where to run your
container
uh the once your container is running
the last stage is going to be the
management of the container management
involves the region of the container
upgrading of the container and so on
and it turns out that um Docker is a
great tool to cover the the first two
steps uh in this life cycle but it
doesn't natively support the the last
two steps stages in this life cycle and
you can use kubernetes to natively
support
um
uh the last two stages
so I want to emphasize that kubernetes
is not a replacement of Docker rather by
using them together you can
fully support this full container life
cycle
and when we think about the relationship
between darker and kubernetes uh there
is awesome documentary on kubernetes
created by Honeypot on YouTube I highly
recommend you to watch this documentary
it's it's really good and
um an interviewer uh asked an
interviewee so what is Docker in
kubernetes anyway and the interviewee's
response is that um so let's imagine we
invent the post office
Docker creates an envelope envelope is a
container and kubernetes is the postal
system that delivers envelopes to the
destination or the VMS
so now we understand the relationship
between Docker and kubernetes uh let's
move on to the kubernetes 101.
so um this gray area is a is the
kubernetes cluster a kubernetes cluster
consists of the control plane and the
workers
control plane is the brain of the
kubernetes it has a scheduler for the
scheduling controller manager for the
maintenance of the container and the hcd
is like the database of the kubernetes
so it's kind of the memory of this brain
and we have an API server talking to the
workers
and control plane can be run on a single
VM or not ovms
and we have workers on each worker we
have a component called the cubelet
cubelet is kind of the agent of each
Walker and it's gonna talk to the API
server receives the request from the API
server process processes the request
um
and uh Walker is just a single VM
so each VM can be a one VM can be a one
Walker
um and you see Parts uh in this diagram
so part uh is a kubernetes component
that executes the containers uh that's
all what it does
and uh it's very unique in kubernetes
that um each part gets its own unique IP
address
so as long as you're in the kubernetes
cluster space you can talk to uh Parts
by using their IP address
so let's go back to the problems we
reviewed how can we build a scalable and
highly available service on using
containers
so the kubernetes answer is called
deployment
a deployment consists of a set of
replicas of the same container from the
same image
um so let's take a look at an example so
we have part A B C and D running on the
on this cluster
um so these parts are identical replicas
of the same container let's say our
machine learning service image
um so let's think about uh how can this
um how this architecture can solve the
issues we had
so scalabit is very straightforward in
this architecture
um since um parts are just identical
replicas they're going to generate the
same response for the same request
so we can just distribute you know a
requests
um across parts
and you can add uh more workers to these
clusters so you can horizontally scale
out your service
what about high availability let's say
uh node one went down that means uh the
parts running on the Node one uh go down
as well and uh but it's not a problem
because we have identical replicas in
node two so when the client sends a
request we can forward the uh for the
request to the node to uh Parts running
on the Note 2. while we recover node one
maybe we can add a new node and create a
random part
foreign
update
um so this is how it works so while you
upgrade
um some parts to a version two uh you
still keep
um some parts alive so when the client
sends a request the request goes to a V1
pods and once V2 paths are ready you can
send a request to the V2 pods and you
can update while you do that you can
update the rest of the V1 pass
so it's not going to be any downtime
for the update
so this is a configuration file
um for deployment in kubernetes you can
write a yaml file to create kubernetes
components so let's take a look at line
two
um applying two you specify the kind
kinda means what kind of components you
want the equivalents to create which is
deployment in this case from from line
three to line seven we can specify the
metadata meta information about this
deployment at line nine you specify the
the number of replicas um for this
deployment and at line 20 you specify
the image associated with this
deployment and align 22 you specify the
port for this service uh by the way this
configuration file is available on my
GitHub
repo so please check it out later
and once you create a yaml file you can
pass the yaml file to the QBC they'll
apply QBC to apply it's going to talk to
the control plane to process your
request
so um and you can check the parts
information using qbctl get parts
um
so this is what your deployment looks
like uh as you can see there are three
parts running for this deployment and
each part gets its own unique IP address
and they are coming from the same image
okay and as I said
um as long as the client is in the
kubernetes space they can send a HTTP
request to a specific part using Parts
IP address
so
this is great but um
the question becomes how can we decide
which part to send a request to since
there is just identical replicas of the
same container
and the kubernetes answer
is called Caster IP service
a Class Type service creates an endpoint
for deployment not for the uh Parts but
for the deployment
in this and the cluster IP works as a
load balancer that distributes traffic
across parts
so in this manner the client can send
the HTTP request to the cost IP and cost
IP it's gonna decide which part to
forward this request uh in this example
because typing decided to use part C so
part C is gonna receive the request and
processes the request uh generates the
response and since it responds back to
the cost IP and cost ip4 is uh the
response back to the client
so this is how you can create a
cost IP service
I put the configuration for the
deployment to emphasize that you need a
deployment to create a service
um
so but this configuration is the same as
the configuration I showed you before
um so let's take a look at the uh
diagram on the right hand side
so this is a configuration for the class
type service
at line 38 you specify the kind which is
service and from line 44 to 46 you
specify the port for this service and
the class ID and at 48 you specify the
deployment associated with this class
type service and at the end of this
configuration you specify the type of
this service which is class IP
and this is what the cost IP looks like
you can get uh service information by
using cubic CTL get services and
um
as you can see cluster IP gets its own
unique IP address and it's listening at
000.
okay so this is great but this gives us
a question let's say we have a legacy
system which cannot be run on kubernetes
but the Legacy system wants to use our
Machinery Service so the question
becomes how can we expose our machine
learning service to outside of
kubernetes
and the kubernetes answer is called node
port
no the port exposes a specific port on
uh all the workers and it's going to
expose the same port on every Walker in
this cluster and in this manner uh the
client can send a HTTP request to any of
the workers at specific node board and
as soon as the request hits the node
Port it's going to be forwarded to the
cluster IB and cluster B does the rest
of the routing
so this is configuration for the node
Port the only difference between uh
configuration for the class IP and the
configuration for the node report is the
last line uh the kind is still serviced
but instead of saying type it's called
type B you say type is node port
and you can as you can see there is no
the port running and
as I said no the port creates cost IP
and exposes a specific code in this case
it decided to expose port 31304
um
so this is great
um Services outside of kubernetes can
talk to our Machinery Service but this
gives us a question how can we decide
which node to send a request to
and the kubernetes answer is called a
load balancer load balancer service
creates a load balancer instance
um outside of kubernetes
and all the balancer distributes traffic
across nodes so there is a distinction
between Class diabetes or the balancing
and the load balances or the balancing
because cost IP is a load balancer for
the parts but load balancer service is
allow the balancer for the nodes
in this manner the client can just send
the HTTP HTTP request to reload the
balancer and it's going to figure out
the rest of the routing and as since
request hits any of the workers specific
node report it's going to be forwarded
to the cost IP and Class Type does the
rest of your route
uh so this is a configuration for the
load balancer service again the only
difference between uh other services
configuration is the last line you
specified that the type is load balancer
um usually you run a load balancer
service on cloud provider
on any cloud provider such as a ALB by
the AWS
but there are some uh on-prem options uh
for the on-prem loader balancer
okay great uh so
our service is fully exposed
um can be accessed
um inside and outside of kubernetes
cluster but this gives us a question
since we are only getting one request
should we run all the four parts aren't
we wasting resources
and the kubernetes community's answer is
called K native K native is a
third-party kubernetes extension that
allows you to create a serverless
service
uh and the K native exposes itself uh
outside of kubernetes so it's going to
create an endpoint accessible from
outside of kubernetes
and the definition of serverless can
vary
um and have multiple meanings
um in this case
um
serverless means that uh there is no
path running uh when there is no request
coming and we run the parts based on the
number of requests
so let's take a look at an example
so let's say the client sends a request
to the k-native instance can native it's
going to check whether any parts
associated with this K native service
running if there is no path running it's
going to ask the API server to create a
new pod API server is going to say no
problem it's going to talk to the
cubelet and cubelet it's gonna create a
pot
and as soon as the part is available
can afford the request to the part and
part is going to process your request
and K native comes with uh many useful
features such as automatic scaling so
it's gonna figure out the number of uh
Parts you need to process incoming
requests so let's take a look at this
example
so as you can see we are getting many
requests from the many clients and
Canada says no problem it's going to
talk to the API server to create more
parts
and the aps server is going to talk to
the qubits on on the Walkers and cubelet
cubelets are gonna create parts and once
parts are ready
okay native uh it's gonna forward the
request to the parts
and this is a configuration for the K
native
[Music]
so let's focus on the line one uh the
first line uh is API version and we are
using K native API uh rather than the
kubernetes native API
and the kind is K native service
and we specify the image associated with
this K native service
and we specify the port for this service
okay so this is a great
um our Machinery Services serverless we
utilize kubernetes resources and we have
to talk about uh important topic
specific to machine learning service
deployment which is models
so Machinery Service deployment is
unique because it involves model
binaries
um
so let's uh think about a simple example
uh let's say one of the data scientists
in your team developed a prediction
model inside key learn
um and you as a Macedonian engineer are
asked to deploy this model as a
microservice so the data scientist is
going to send you this model binary in
psychi learn to you I hope she uses SCP
not email
sorry
and um but you as a machine engineer
receives this uh secular model and
creates a image including this model
binary and you push the image to image
repository kubernetes it's going to pull
the image from the image repository and
schedule the Run parts
so this is like okay as long as you're
in a small team but as you can see we
deal with uh two identical copies of the
same model binary which is not great
what if uh your team uh grows and you
get more data scientists uh asking you
to deploy their models and each data
scientist may use you know different
machine learning framework and each
machine learning framework has its own
dependency requirements so
and you as a machine learning engineer
you receive lots of model binaries and
you have to keep them in your
environment so it's going to be hard to
keep track of the lineage of machine
learning models once they're deployed
and the communication issue it's going
to be inevitably happen
and
this happens
we don't know which model we're running
so how can we solve this issue
um one way to solve this uh problem is
to use model registry
I'm gonna talk about ml4 model resistry
as an example in this talk but um ml4
model resistry uh creates
um
centralized model storage and
for for a story in the model binaries in
this manner data scientists can just
push their model binaries into ml4 model
registry and ml4 stores lots of metadata
metadata meta information about the
models and you as a machine learning
engineer can view the information
through ml flow UI and you can figure
out the the model name and model version
for your service and you can create and
you can pass the ml flow um connection
information to your image then you can
create an image and push the image to
image repository and once the kubernetes
pulls the image you can program your
script to fetch model binaries from the
ml4 model registry in this manner manner
you only deal with single model binaries
and that's a great deal
this is what the ml4 UI looks like as
you can see it contains lots of meta
information
such as creation time of this model last
modified time description tags version
is very important because we potentially
develop lots of models as a we're going
to have a multiple versions for the same
model
and uh there's also um a tag for the
staging information so maybe you as a
machine learning engineer can say okay
maybe I should use version one because
it's tagged production
so it massively simplifies the um uh
Machinery Service development process
and this is the example uh script to
deal with ML flow model registry so left
hand side shows how to register your
model in ml4 model registry uh first
component is the uh the training of your
model and once you train random first
model you establish connection at the ml
film model registry and you log the
model there
so maybe uh this is a script for the
data scientist
and once the model is pushed and you're
asked to deploy this model as a
microservice you can make the flask app
fetch the model when you start when it
gets started
you can pass the important information
model name version ml for your URI in
environment variables and first it's
going to establish the connection to the
ml4 model registry and close the model
from there and pass passes the model to
the first Gap and your app is ready to
serve
so maybe the second script is for the
machine learning engineers
okay so this is the final configuration
file for our machine learning service I
promise you there is no more
so from line one to eleven uh it's
identical
um but sorry line one two
fourteen yeah
but from line 14 to uh to the end
um I specify the
environment variables so this is how you
can specify environment
environmental variables uh in kubernetes
and also you can secret uh you can use a
secret to store a sensitive information
within the kubernetes space and you can
use the secret as an environmental
variable so this is how you can do it
okay uh so before I go I wanna quickly
talk about how I set up my uh kubernetes
cluster for this demo
um so for this demo I just used the
vanilla uh Native VMS uh offered by this
is the ocean and
um I just I didn't use the uh the
kubernetes product I just used their
vanilla VMS
um and for uh my kubernetes cluster I
used a three Notes One node is for the
control plane uh two notes for the
walkers for the workers you only need
one gigabyte of memory and one CPU this
is okay but for the control plane you
need two gigabytes for memory and one
CPU otherwise you're not gonna have a
pleasant experience
um and as long as you don't run crazy
number of services this is these
configuration is enough for demo
um and to set up my kubernetes cluster I
used a kubernetes distribution called
k3s
okay 3s is a certified kubernetes
distribution
that allows you to create the kubernetes
cluster that requires much less
resources
um
if you wanna run vanilla kubernetes
cluster this config configuration is not
going to be enough you're going to need
more computation powers like k3s is a
lightweight kubernetes so uh this is
gonna be uh enough for quesades
and um
and the k3s comes with a single binary
so it massively simplifies the
installation process it's really really
easy to install uh vanilla kubernetes uh
it's not very easy kubernetes is great
because it's flexible kubernetes is bad
because it's flexible
and on my k3s cluster I run K native and
for the image repository I use a darker
hub for the ml4 model resistry I use one
gigabytes of memory and one CPU VM on
this the ocean I and I run it outside of
kubernetes and
I run ml4 server as a Docker container
and I use the scfdp server as the
backend storage for this ml flow storage
so thank you very much
um
yeah we can get started okay
yeah thank you very much for your talk
it was very nice I have a question in
particular about the challenges you face
because in the way you show it
kubernetes are awesome and it was very
shiny and very clear but I would like to
know if you have faced any particular
challenge with this workflow or some
similar workflows that you have had
um
in a more realistic scenario
so I think your question is about like
is there any uh challenges I faced uh
when I set up my kubernetes course yes
um that's a great question
um first of all it's hard to set up
kubernetes uh and uh so kubernetes is a
distributed systems so it's a vulnerable
to like network issues so it's sometimes
it breaks uh and you want your notes to
be highly available so if they're on the
same rack let's say in a data center
if the racket goes down everything goes
down so maybe you want to use a cloud
providers some VM for maybe some
components like uh control plane
but that's a great question thank you
could you just show the slide again
where you had the the link to your
GitHub and all that thanks thank you for
that
I have a question for over here yes
pertaining to when you were beginning to
speak about k-native and how it was able
to like as opposed to extending a lot of
resources monetary compute otherwise it
will listen for
your API requests and then spin up pods
accordingly
um from a practicality perspective like
when the first request comes in
then wouldn't that take time to build
from an image from the start so wouldn't
you just need to like at least have one
persisting like one pod existing
in terms of like live production
deployment yeah that's a great question
so the question is about uh I think it's
called warm start or code start so if
there's no path running we have to
create a pot and uh so what about you
know the downtime uh the answer is yes
uh and it depends on the size of your
machine learning model if the model is
Big you know it takes lots of uh i o
connection you know time
um and I think it depends on your use
case
um
you can configure K native to run you
know at least one service at one part
yeah so that's possible and um
I think I forgot to mention but the
advantage of using K native uh for
serverless services that um
um so it's still kubernetes so it's
gonna be portable so you can put your
commands cluster between Cloud providers
yeah thank you for the question thank
you
um
have you ever set this up in like a
production configuration
um we
we are using different kubernetes
distribution for the production and it's
more suitable for production purposes uh
and I work in uh Healthcare so I we have
to set up on-prem kubernetes cluster
because it's hard to migrate to the
cloud for some regulation reasons but um
yeah
um I had a lot of fun setting up the
cluster I would say
okay yeah yep I mean I worked for
Healthcare Company too and we used
to
um
please talk to my you know manager
hey so thanks for first of all thanks
for your informative essential you did
talk about load balancer right so when
you choose load balancer is there a
specific list of ips you can cover or
they can talk about different subnets
how does you can figure that up when you
set up kubernetes are you talking about
cost IP or the restaurant yes yeah you
can set up a range uh even you can set
up a IP range for the parts using the
cider
so it's expensive cider cidr it's the
idea okay forget that you know but what
it stands for okay and can they talk
with different subnets or is they can
only work with one set of software ah so
that's gonna be a difficult question
um it depends on how you set up you know
subnet because kubernetes does not set
up subnet right it uses existing
supplement so usually it creates an
overlay network uh using UDP you know
connection I UDP tunnels um but there is
a way to
formulate kubernetes cluster without
UDP tunnel it's called um
Calico so you it's gonna do IP in IP uh
packet packaging and you can talk the
other subnets but it's a kind of
advanced topic and it's fully like
devops you know yeah I love to talk
about it but yeah thank you
your ml flow set up do you
do YouTube users any kind of tenancy
requirements below one model
right yeah so that's a great question
the question is um like you're talking
about multi-tenancy right for the ml4
um we don't have it we love to have it
um but I don't think uh ml4 natively
supports that so I was wondering if you
had built something
that would be a cool poster I mean see
my Twitter list yeah
yeah I think we have time for one last
question
yes what is the
difference between kubernetes
as the distributions you've been using
and versus Google cloud and how it and
how much easier is it or harder
um that's an interesting question
um so Google cloud is more broad it
covers more services
um Google provides a
kubernetes service called gke
so it's not an apple to Apple comparison
in my opinion but when it comes to other
distributed systems such as mesos yarn
which was the darkest one kubernetes is
known to be more stable
but it's more complicated
um apologies to the others who have
questions yeah um and thanks a lot uh
thank you Kai for the amazing session